all right it's a whole Barbie hour so
let's finish up with something that
celebrates the iconic toy this is what
I'm liking
who says playing with dolls is just for
kiddos a Maryland woman recently
discovered her passion for Barbies and
she's blowing up social media with
videos of what she calls Minnie me now
in the clips you can see Minnie me now
doing everyday tasks like figuring out
what to wear from her exclusive and
extensive mini closet or winding down
after a long day her videos have racked
up millions of views y'all we have her
on the line right now to tell us more
let's say hi to me now watching on NBC
Washington
all right hi me now don't you say dolls
are kind of new in your life right yeah
so growing up I never really saw dolls
that really looked like me or really
like represented me for who I was so it
wasn't until recently where
um I saw a doll's on the shelves kind of
diversify a little more and that's when
I started collecting
I started like you know building more
sets for them and I started to collect
more things the pandemic also you know
aided in that because it kind of
reignited my love for crafting and that
coupled with my newfound love for dolls
kind of helped me form what my Tick Tock
is today I would collect miniature items
for My Mini-Me like food and furniture
and yeah I wanted her to really reflect
who I was I love crafting as well um so
you've developed serious skills though
in the videos and in crafting so one of
you learned and what's next for you well
most of what I have learned it's a bit
self-taught for example I started
um doing stop motion in my videos I
would take my mini me I'd move her take
another picture move her snap another
picture and it'd be that repetitive
process until I made you know a cute
little movie or a video I also started
making doll houses and doll rooms for My
Mini-Me some something new that I would
love to get into for my doll and I is
traveling more I definitely want to
travel with her more I want to take
pictures with her out more I've been to
DC and I've been to New York with her
but I would really love to take her to
the beach oh my gosh I love this and by
the way my kids are obsessed with
watching like the stop-motion stuff like
they would love this um and also my kids
loved all so thanks so much me Nell I'm
liking your post right now I hope you
get to the beach
and that's not all mamar season long
partner pilot pen makers of friction the
go-to-raceable pin of the Kelly Clarkson
show want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like yourself ma'am so
to get you to the beach and to help you
out they're going to give you a thousand
dollars
[Applause]
so much to all of our guests
Aaron y'all have a great day and if it's
not time changing
[Music]
foreign
guys I'm going
[Music]